moi ça va on n'a même pas où le tour dès
que j'étais ton anniversaire hier on
aurait dit que tu t es monté au
rez-de-chaussée de la montagne coque de
alors que vous s'est passé ces deux
grands voisins ce centre de la ville non
j'ai du travail en bas je vous laisse
c'était fabuleux qu'est ce que tu as vu
de si fabuleux une petite chanteuse à
lunettes qui veut jamais les m mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ça ces
merveilleuses et comme un oiseau en
équilibre sur des petits talons aiguille
elle a quelque chose de fragile et
intense à la fois un je ne sais quoi de
brindilles correspond la santé le son
est comme celui d'un oiseau mais avec
des mots et le nez magnifiquement bien
dessiné si minuscules que je me demande
comment elle fait pour respirer avec
arme a vidé juste là pour décorer il est
trop petit sonné c'est pour ça que
rapporte pas ses lunettes au moins deux
petit roeulx elle doit regonfler comme
une locomotive à non un appareil ne peut
que produire un son de flûte